neueste erkenntnisse zum bienensterben
jetzt zwei klicks um 25 ticks zu das
bienensterben ist eine große bedrohung
fünf menschen forscher arbeiten auf
hochtouren
dieses unaufhaltsam scheinende problem
zu bekämpfen neonicotinoide wie claude
tianyi die imidacloprid und metro farm
ich hab richtig ausgesprochen sollen
hauptverantwortlich für das insekten
sterben waren diese insektizide greifen
das nervensystem der insekten an und
schädigen dieses dadurch enorm obwohl
der einsatz von länger durch behörden
eingeschränkt wurde scheint es noch
immer genügend schlupflöcher bzw
erlaubte verwendungszwecke zu geben dass
so viele insekten dadurch sterben eine
neue untersuchung stellt jetzt sogar
auch noch bis dato erlaubte und
eigentlich für in ordnung befunden
stoffe stark in frage
die rede ist von zoua 3 000 oder 300
mann ist ein sogenanntes benetzung
mittel das im agrarbereich zum schutz
der pflanzen eingesetzt wird die
forscher der pennsylvania state
university im fachmagazin scientific
reports berichten weiter silikon aber
nicht so in ordnung wie vielleicht wie
fair eingeordnet wurde in laborversuchen
stellte sich heraus versorger 309 vor
allem bienenlarven erheblichen schaden
zufügen kann zitat im web v6 common use
organe philly konstant zu gab's wie oh
nein
negative impact the help of honey bee
low bei increasing respekt militär kamen
die pathologin wird black wings lvs
berichtet julia feist rang neun stört
also womöglich das immunsystem der
heranwachsenden bienen und machte eben
für dieses virus angreifbar ob das
tatsächlich einen großen beitrag zum
bienensterben leitet das muss noch
geklärt werden sollte sich das
bienensterben nicht in den griff
bekommen lassen wird es schlimme folgen
haben wissenschaftler der harvard chan
hochschule für gesundheitswesen haben in
der fachzeitschrift the lancet eine
studie veröffentlicht die die folgen
daraus im zahlen nennt was passiert wenn
alle bienen aussterben der studie nach
dem bahn 23% früchte
16 prozent gemüse 22 müsse und 20
prozent getreide verloren und diese
prozent zahlen beziehen sich alle auf
den weltweiten bestand also echt übel
für uns aus was denkt ihr wie schätzt
ihr die gefahren durch das bienensterben
einlassen wir eure meinung dazu in den
kommentaren da und wenn euch das video
gefallen hat ist auch gerne einen daumen
nach oben da und um keine news her auf
lithium zu verpacken abonniert und dafür
hier kostenlos einfach klicken
unternehmen wir uns schon morgen wieder
biss dann bleibt dran